the refactoring you just completed gets
our code ready to use the weather
provider for this quiz you're going to
code the ad location method as you can
see this method takes a location setting
city name latitude and longitude for the
new location if the location already
exists we returned the ID of the
existing location if we add a location
we return the ID of the added location
we can do this by first querying the
content provider to see if the location
query already exists and only performing
the insert if it doesn't yet exist
uncomment test add location within test
fetchweathertask
to validate your solution